when I review or try to describe my
creativity I realized it's a it's a
non-stop train and people say yeah well
at some point you you go to sleep
well actually this moment when we think
we rest when the brain is a is floating
you know in in sleep is actually a
moment where I could be very creative in
a very strange uncontrolled way
metaphorically speaking of course if I
put a problem behind my pillow and fall
asleep very often because my brain went
to sleep with that idea with that
problem alive very often in the middle
of the night I wake up and I wake up
with a solution with a direction of
solution and I always have a little
notepad and a pen because when I wake up
in the middle of the night if I don't
immediately jot the solution to my
problem it evaporates in sinaia and I
wake up naturally the next morning
having forgotten the incident even if
you experiment that if you if you fall
asleep with an idea that is not solved
yet you might very well wake up
naturally or wake up you know before you
wake up naturally with some sense of the
solution and I find that fascinating and
it's not something unique to me so try
it and you'll be amazed too
you